relation guys are such [ __ ] this
audience for a late supper you really do
it's out tight we work energy in the air
like shitty HR we work Elizabeth
Warren's gonna lose again that's what it
feels a little bit not all of you but
the majority of you know you know we'll
just work you go tweet Isis we work
locations all day like they are
disrespecting the Prophet on Bleeker
let's see this is this is why your
[ __ ] I'm in a job that's a [ __ ]
stupids different products to do
midnight in a basement it's a job do you
know what I mean Trump is gonna win the
next nine times that's the problem
you all suck so much as people you know
really is gonna be oh no joke at the
show that's joke I
they don't kill themselves after the
show it's not were you gonna do easy to
kill yourself in your car because I mean
is a fat guy yelled at you gonna blow
your brains out before you go to the
Tappan Zee Bridge to Sleepy Hollow or
the [ __ ] shitty Big Brother live here
now this is a big [ __ ] mall this
seems disgusting it's you want to be
fouling up here that's what you want you
want to be Fallon doing jokes with
Muppets that's what Valentine's he plays
checkers with Miss Piggy he's coked out
of his head and they chained him to that
desk so it doesn't bite someone's tit
and they have that lawsuit again that's
the other thing that you guys deserve
this country deserve that's what you
deserve you deserve
Ellen dancing with Bush and Abu Ghraib
choking people and chloroforming people
[ __ ] Ellen
[ __ ] Ellen she socks it basic [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] she sucks
she sucks everything you like socks